I think swearing in a business setting
is okay once or twice a year when it is
totally called for and appropriate when
something is just so head smacking ly
stupid that you have to swear about it
when you want to confront your boss it's
okay to do is once or twice a year if
anything it'll show that you know you're
awake and you're aware you're not asleep
at the switch and you're not just some
kind of sick of fun so yes okay but the
question is are you doing it once or
twice a year in cases that are really
called for or is that your general
personality is it your general
personality that you you you fight
everything and that you resist
everything and you know basically I'm
asking are you just a pain in the ass
because pain in the asses are not
enchanting and pain enhances do not
advance